wir sehen sie ein az er das ist ein
aufklärungsrate gerät wie es in der luft
helfen das ist auch schon bundeswehr im
einsatz ist die aufklärung von
hinzuweisen ladegeräte des rhader
bataillons werden bei luftraumsicherung
operationen eingesetzt um eine
flächendeckende bedingung für den
konferenz orten tagungsorten oder
sonstigen objekten sicherzustellen wenn
eine schwergewichtige überwachung
verschiedener räume erforderlich ist um
den maximalen schutz zu garantieren und
die aufklärung und viel zu weisen und
radiogeräte des rhader partner zum
einsatz gemeinsam mit den abfangjäger
luft stellen die teile des bataillons am
boden schutz der konferenzen und
tagungen im rahmen der eu
ratspräsidentschaft sichert
[Musik]